à toute allure les ambulances rapatrie
une trentaine de soldats turquie
grièvement blessé ces militaires qui ont
survécu aux attaques des forces de damas
sont rapidement prises en charge dans
cet hôpital tout proche de la frontière
syrienne
une trentaine d'autres ont été tués des
soins sont encore prodigués aux autres
blessées dans notre hôpital
encore une fois que dieu accorde la paix
à leurs âmes
je souhaite une guérison rapide à nos
blessés mes condoléances à leurs
familles à notre nation et la situation
pourrait continuer d'empirer les forces
d'ankara ont déjà lancé leur riposte et
annonce avoir mené des bombardements sur
des positions des forces syriennes à
idlib le président turc recep tayyip
erdogan à lui convoqué un conseil de
sécurité extraordinaire à ankara
cette escalade militaire entre les deux
pays continuent d'inquiéter la
communauté internationale le conflit a
déjà fait des dizaines de milliers de
déplacés selon l'onu des dizaines de
milliers de personnes vivent maintenant
dans des abris de fortune dans des
bâtiments publics en plein air duty sous
les arbres exposés à la pluie et à la
neige dans le froid glacial du rigoureux
hiver syrien il sera très lente sur ces
camps de fortune à idlib sur les enfants
et les enseignants tué de manière
horrible il y à peine deux jours alors
que dix écoles ont été attaqués sont à
la fois répréhensible et moralement
répugnante
de son côté le secrétaire général de
l'otan jens stoltenberg a de nouveau
exhorté les différentes parties à la
désescalade tandis que les etats-unis
ont réaffirmé leur soutien la turquie
pour sa part moscou estime que ankara
soutient les djihadistes opposés au
gouvernement syrien et de ce fait ne
respectent pas la corde désescalade
conclu en 2018 hier un nouveau round de
pourparlers entre les deux pays n'a pas
permis de trouver une issue au conflit
les négociations doivent se poursuivre
[Musique]